[Music]
break into programming to take you live
to pictures out of the poland belarus
border where we understand that polish
authorities have used tear gas stung
grenades and water cannon as well as
warning shots to try and repel an
attempt by migrants who are there to
force their way across the border let's
listen in to what's happening
they said that they are ready to receive
these refugees the belarus president
said that his country is ready to open
an ur lift
to let these people arrive to munich if
the
as he said the
german authorities are serious in their
statements
and the whole situation
is complicated
and just to let you know that that is
the al jazeera arabic correspondent our
sister channel who is the reporter right
there on the ground so we're listening
in
to what he has to say as he's describing
the situation that's unfolding right now
belarus forces never
attempt to take any action
or to prevent them to reach the siege
between
the fence between belarusia and poland
this is quite
astonishing because they are only
watching they are only monitoring
they are there on the other side
be
on this side they are just
waiting there protecting their vehicles
protecting themselves
but
not allowing these refugees
to go
beyond this point this border point
and i think we need to mention this
because this
has raised a lot of exclamation marks
the police now i think
tear gas
as you can see and i can feel
if we if we
connect
what's going on with the announcement of
the belarusian president
we could understand the situation of
belarus
he said his country is not
ready
to protect
the borders of the european union
because his country doesn't have enough
force enough capabilities in order to
secure the borders so this can be
an explanation
and
of the whole situation following the
lusty
presidential elections and the
diplomatic
battle between belarusia and
the west some of the western companies
did not
recognize and admit the result of the
presidential elections so
he said
his country is not ready to protect the
borders of the european union if the
european union wants to protect his
borders from the refugees so he has to
finance and to provide the financial
capabilities and to go into
direct
talks with the authorities of his
country
the foreign minister of belarus vladimir
mckay
and joseph borel talked few days ago
also contacts between lokasheko and
merkel yesterday probably
this is the
aim of
the belarusian authorities
because of the whole situation
[Music]
so this is the scene right now this is a
developing situation on the
poland belarus border where
as you can see on your screen right now
uh the polish authorities
are using tear gas as well as stun
grenades and water cannon
and they're firing warning shots as well
and what they're trying to do is to
repel an attempt by
the migrants who have been on that
border
for the the past few days now
they're trying to stop them from
crossing
across the border and that is uh al
jazeera arabic's correspondent right
there in the thick of it
at the scene
let's listen in once again to to his
reporting and his describing of the
situation
and
they have almost nothing we will try now
to
talk
to them or to see what
is the reaction i can see
children and as you can see these
uh
everything that they can have for
the time being
they were dreaming of trying to cross
last night was tough
there is a lack of medicine food
and the temperature went down yesterday
on the zero
and
this area is very cold you can see
children
you can see children
and
they have nothing
this tent will never protect anyone
from the weather
from the freezing weather they spend
here
last night that's why we can see also
this lady and this
how old is he seven months
these are very humanitarian cases
difficult ones
we didn't sleep since yesterday our feet
are
freezing
the only word that we can hear is
attention attention attention
and the
we have kids we have wives
nothing
nothing happened if they don't want to
allow us then let them return us back to
our country
we did not eat for five days only food
is little and available for women and
kids
we
need a safe place
we need a safe country
people say that we are rich no we are
not rich we need a stable country where
we can live and establish ourselves
everyone wants to work and wants to
study
families did not sleep the whole night
yesterday
last night look at our hands look at our
fingers freezing
no media is here to see what is our
situation
give us little food but we are here in
big numbers
we are not writing we are not writing
it's it's a very humanitarian cases here
we've met this refugee few days ago he
was he is from iraq he was sick
he had an operation
to plant his kidney
and he needs medicine
he can
the operation like 10 or 11 months ago
and yesterday it was freezing i took my
jacket for them last night because of
the cold weather no food no water
nothing nothing
they gave us little food
but it's not enough for us
you told me that you will try to get
some medicine
yes i have to take this medicine forever
i did not get any medicine until now i
must take this medicine i must find this
medicine
this is the the situation here
every one of these refugees has his own
problem his own humanitarian case and
the situation is very difficult very
difficult
once again these are exclusive pictures
coming to us here at al jazeera with our
coverage of this developing story with
al jazeera arabic's correspondent on the
ground right now
on the belarus poland border describing
the dire
humanitarian situation for migrants who
are stuck there let's listen in once
again
they said that they have paid a hell lot
of money for them to arrive here in this
area in this spot
and
they have
they have
received a lot of promises that they
will reach germany end of the day but it
seems that they cannot go back to iraq
because they don't have work in iraq
they don't have shelter in iraq that's
why
the situation here is very decisive i
think that the majority don't want to go
back there are some diplomatic
contacts for the refugees to go back to
their country
but
according to those who
have talked to us they reject
categorically to go back to iraq and
they said
it's
a destiny it's a journey either to reach
germany or to say until
they
find what will happen to them
[Music]
and as you can see
the tents can never
protect
anyone from the cold weather here
it's freezing particularly during the
night
and
they distributed light meals
for
women and children
some milk
some bread
some cans
some mood for heating summit for the
children
and
they also
offer some
little urgent medical
assistance there are so many cases where
the fingers have been frozen
pregnant women went into coma
and the situation is not
enough and
let's say
the help is little the president of
belarusia
said
that his country cannot increase the
assistances because
they don't have enough and he urged the
europeans
to intervene
exclusive pictures from the poland
belarus border where you can see a
situation
unfolding and developing between the the
migrants who have been stranded there as
well as polish
authorities and uh
just a few moments ago we were looking
at the the live picture of polish
authorities using tear gas stung
grenades as well as water cannon
um and what they're doing is they're
trying to sort of disperse the migrants
and repel the migrants attempts
to force their way across the border
reportedly
let's listen in
once again
all right so
we'll
cross back to hear what the al jazeera
reporter has to say
in just a moment but
these are the live and exclusive
pictures
coming through to us the migrants have
been telling the reporter of harrowing
stories
which include a lack of medicine
at the border as well as lack of food
and as you can see
pretty freezing conditions cold
conditions for the migrants uh to be in
over the past
couple of days or so so this situation
is just unfolding and developing
right now as polish authorities
as polish
authorities
use tear gas
and stun grenades and water cannon to
try and disperse the the migrants
currently at that border let's uh bring
in step vassen right now step is joining
us from kusnica that's near the polar
side of the border
with belarus
steph you're not exactly there but from
what i understand you're
you're in the vicinity you certainly are
aware of what's going on
these are some pretty shocking images
coming into us right now exclusively
dramatic scenes right at the gate at the
of the european union here at the polish
border of course pictures that will not
go down well here in many european
countries a real clash between the
polish border guards and migrants and
asylum seekers on the other side of
course these are images that are now
filmed and spread also by the belarusian
state media russian media are there as
well these are of course also images
that the belarusian authorities want the
world to see that the european union is
treating asylum seekers and migrants
this way this harsh way let them there
in the cold not letting them in to seek
refuge here at this side of the border
there's a lot of tension here as well
lots of police i'm exactly three
kilometers away from where this is
happening the polish government has
imposed an emergency situation meaning
that they have restricted the access
three kilometers away from us now this
is all unfolding uh quite rapidly it
seems there's going to be a force onto
this border it was been reported days
ago already that there would be the
so-called storm at the border of course
migrants and asylum seekers have become
increasingly desperate they've been
repeatedly told that they can go to
germany easily
the belarusian authorities have also
said that
they will go to germany that it they
will be accepted by germany these
stories have been spread around so of
course they're very desperate to get
there it's extremely cold here now the
winter of course has started and there
are not enough means there in the
meantime there are diplomatic efforts
going on between the belarusian leader
alexander lukashanka and germany
directly he has been speaking to angela
merkel once yesterday a very significant
phone call because
nobody in the eu wanted to talk to
lukashenka since he was accused of
orchestrating his re-election last year
but now they're negotiating with him to
see if there's an end to this crisis and
he announced this morning that he will
have another phone call probably today
step
you you're covering the story and i know
that you've seen firsthand the condition
of the migrants and we just heard a few
moments ago live on our air exclusively
one of the migrants speaking to al
jazeera describing that there was pretty
much no medicine he was saying that
there was been for them
it's been a
very very desperate and these are people
are still at the belarusian side in the
camp of course the situation there is
really bad but
so police is really heading to this uh
border situation right now
but there's also people
every night people manage to cross
somehow through this border fence
getting into the polish forest and there
they have also very difficult situation
because the polish border guards pick
them up and push them back into belarus
and some of the migrants and asylum
seekers i've been speaking to people
from yemen from iraq they sat they told
me they have been pushed back
and forth
maybe 10-20 times so they have been
ping-ponged between those countries for
weeks some have spent like three weeks
in the forest with their children with
their family and some were lucky enough
to get through poland not being caught
by the border guards and actually end up
in germany and in the netherlands in
germany and in the netherlands there are
a few thousand who have actually made
the journey but many others of course
have been hospitalized
some have died
there's also now today this morning a
report from a father of a syrian boy who
also died in the forest he is blaming
the polish authorities for his fate
because the polish authorities have not
done anything to help them
and
step as we continue to watch these
exclusive pictures
do we know what exactly sparked this
confrontation
well what sparked it exactly this
morning is not clear the belarusian
state tv says people are increasingly
hungry they are increasingly cold
they're desperate so they made an
attempt for the border fence that's
their explanation it's not clear exactly
many journalists also international
journals who are at that side of the
border can't get to the scene at the
moment so it's very difficult to verify
exactly what sparked the conflict but it
was rumored to be happening for a couple
of days already there were increasingly
reports and also spread around
among the migrants and asylum seekers
that they could go to germany yesterday
or they could go to germany today so
they always been hoping the gate will
open
that's exactly what has been promised to
them so of course you can ex you can
understand the mindset that they've been
waiting there uh in this very dire
situation and hoping that something will
happen and that's probably what sparked
the the conflict this morning this riot
the first time that the polish border
guards had really used violence have
used water cannons
they have used stun grenades we actually
heard warning shots not clear where they
came from but there has been the serious
clash at the border right here behind me
step just earlier uh today as we were
talking earlier on actually the the
belarusian leader alexander lukashenko
had said that he wants to
avoid what he called confrontation over
the migrant crisis at his country's
border with poland i mean
we will obviously wait and see what
reaction comes through to this
developing situation right now but but
how do you think these authorities will
be looking
at this situation
[Music]
well yeah alexander lukashenko said one
thing this morning about avoiding a
confrontation and
the next minute we see a confrontation
at the border and as my colleague uh
from al jazeera arabic explains the
belarusian authorities have not done
anything to stop the confrontation
between the migrants and asylum seekers
on one hand and the polish border troops
on the other they were standing there
they have been
looking
at what was happening not intervening
not protecting the border so of course
it is
clearly a confrontation that has been
happening
and it's not clear what
alexander lukashenka
is his next plan we know that he's been
talking to angela merkel maybe there's
going to be some kind of solution they
had a very long phone call yesterday
which is significant 15 minutes so and
he will have a next call he said because
there's been an offer on the table it's
very interesting of course to find out
what exactly has been offered by the eu
because the eu didn't want to give in to
this crisis because they said he has
masterminded it
has masterminded
in response to the sanctions that eu has
imposed on him so
while i'm speaking you can see that
increasingly police is rushing to the
border to enforce the border because of
course poland is very worried that there
will be this breakthrough that people
will actually break through this border
and
come into the country
massively and that's the main fear that
they have had here for the last weeks
and increasingly now today
uh steph vassen they're on the polish
side of the belarussian polish border
steph it's nostalgia tay here in doha
joining you thanks so much for staying
abreast of this for us as we've been
saying we've been seeing some really
dramatic pictures from the other side of
the border and i can see there that um
there are there's an a buildup on the
polish side as well steph i'm curious
we've been hearing reports now for some
days that
that the bella russian side the bella
russian authorities have actually been
encouraging people to go to the border
literally showing people there the way
through the forest even handing out wire
cutters
is there any
any truth to these statements
well i've been speaking to many migrants
and asylum seekers who exactly confirmed
that that they had
help from the belarusian authorities to
enter minsk in the first place you know
they paid money to get a visa an entry
visa and then they were shown the way to
the border
got a taxi and then basically been
directed by the belarusian border police
to the polish border they were literally
brought to the border and sometimes even
pushed through the border i spoken to
one asylum seeker from yemen who is now
in germany he explained to me that he
got
a cutter to cut the wire because there's
barbed wire on the border he was
literally handed out this
this cutter to go through the wire and
that's not the only person who has told
this story so there's clearly evidence
that the belarusian border police or the
troops who are now in charge at the
border have been actively helping
the migrants and asylum seekers to break
through
the border and if people really wanted
to go back because the same person told
me he spent 10 days in the cold in
between these borders being ping-ponged
between the two forces he said he backed
to let him go back to minsk let me go
back because i can't do this anymore and
then the belarusian
police told him no you can't go back you
have to go to poland and he got a gun
against his hat that that's what he told
me step it looks very very dramatic
there on the border sorry to interrupt i
do believe that we are getting a direct
report from from the migrants and our
correspondent there who's with them as
this altercation escalates i'm just
gonna i'm gonna bring him in and listen
to what he has to do is
the effect of
firing tear gas
yeah there are some
and everyone has with a drone
as you can see this spot over there is
empty now because everyone
uh withdrew
because of the heavy firing
of tear gas and the heavy use of water
cannons
is this the human rights of europe
are these the human rights in europe
ten days
we've been here without water
temperatures is minus five and what can
we do
where are the human rights organizations
where are the organizations for human
rights
we were a good country they have
invaded iraq in 2003
what will happen if you are not allowed
we've lost everything we've sold our
cars we've sold our houses they
destroyed our country
they destroyed our country and now this
is the human rights where are the human
rights where is europe
the situation is very critical
and
the most affected people are the
children and the kids you can see
you can see now this child
is
it's everywhere in this we can call it a
peaceful area
we have seen
women we have seen
kids
who
suffer suffocation
there are kids who are suffering and
women who are suffering and also men who
are suffering
from suffocation because of the
tear gas
everyone is now standing here
to see what's going on because the
polish forces have used
pepper tea gas
and probably the polish forces managed
to
force these people to withdraw
because they are trying
the refugees were trying to get closer
to the fence
suffocation
because they have been doing this
for like two hours now
uh
they say
by rock o'clock they will try to go
through
the fence but i think the
polish side
will never allow anyone to get closer
to the fence